- You're not going to
increase your revenue,
your traffic, your sales
unless you take growth seriously.
Perfection is overrated.
Nothing's ever perfect.
You're going to continue
to have to iterate,
so forth, so on.
Why would you expect someone
to just come to your website
and be like hey, buy something for $1,000.
Okay, here's my credit card, right?
- He's an entrepreneur, investor,
and analytics expert.
He's best known as the co-founder
of KISSmetrics and Crazy Egg.
In addition to founding companies,
he's well-regarded as
a writer and a blogger.
He's Neil Patel, and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best.
Also, as Neil is talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(air rushing)
(uplifting orchestral music)
- Before we get started,
I want to tell you one quote
from a guy named Adam Nash,
and it's very important, in which
"Growth is important,
"and all good companies
take it seriously."
You're not going to increase your revenue,
your traffic, your sales
unless you take growth seriously.
For example, you know Facebook.
You know what their internal metric
when they first started out was?
How many more users were
they adding per day?
And they weren't just looking
at it as a pure number.
So if they had 1,000 users the first day
and the second day they
had another 1,000 users
and then the third day they
had another new 1,000 users,
that's slowing growth.
Percentage-wise, you're
not growing as fast.
So their goal was to grow a faster percent
than the previous day, right?
If you take growth seriously,
you can actually do quite well.
You need to execute,
and you need to execute
as fast as possible.
Because the thing at the end of the day is
whether you feel you
have competitors or not,
sooner or later you're
going to have someone,
and if you can't move fast enough,
someone's going to beat you to the punch.
So make sure whatever you're doing,
you get something out
within a month or two.
If it takes you longer than that,
you're taking way too long.
I created this company called Serph,
and it was in Rockwell, Texas,
right by Dallas.
And I had this brilliant idea.
Have any of you guys heard of
the Media Temple grid server solution?
That was my idea a year
or two before it came out.
And I spent a million bucks on it
trying to actually do that
idea before Media Temple.
The funny thing is I didn't
have a million bucks,
so I actually had to
borrow a million bucks,
and I spent it on business
partners who moved really slow
and really weren't the
best at what they did.
Within 12 months, we launched nothing.
They also had some of the problems
in my previous slide, right,
like financial instability
and they had a family and
kids of I think, like, six.
So I even bought 'em a
home in Rockwell, Texas
that cost 200 and something thousand.
Why did I buy it instead of renting it?
I have no clue.
I was stupid and young.
But nonetheless, I lost
over a million bucks
on that of borrowed money.
Not investor money, but borrowed money
that I had to pay back.
And it failed miserably because
we never launched anything.
If you can't launch something,
someone like Media Temple's
going to beat you to the bunch,
get a ton of customers,
and make a lot of money.
So lessons I learned from that.
Set deadlines.
No matter what, you have to set deadlines.
People have to be held
accountable to 'em as well, right?
You can't just set a deadline,
it passes, nothing happens.
Someone better be meeting 'em.
If not, you know, something has to change.
You also need to make sure they're small.
If the deadline, if the milestones, goals
are too big for those deadlines,
they're not going to get met,
so make 'em really small and tangible.
That way you can see it
really well in advance
if they're actually
going to be met or not.
And last but not least,
don't worry about perfection.
A lot of people, like,
dude, I'm going to create
the most perfect version of,
you know, whatever it may be.
That software has a lot of buzz.
Mine's going to be perfect.
Perfection is overrated.
Nothing's ever perfect.
You're going to continue
to have to iterate
so forth, so on.
It's never going to be perfect.
There's always going to be issues.
Just get it out there and
start trying to make money.
I continually learn from my mistakes
and other people's mistakes.
See, entrepreneurs think that,
hey, to create that billion-dollar company
or hundred-million-dollar company
or even million-dollar company
you have to be really smart,
and sure, brains is part of it,
luck is a huge component.
But what I've learned over the years
is everyone, no matter how smart you are,
you're going to fail many times
and you're going to make mistakes.
Just look at Mark Zuckerberg.
Facebook worked out.
His version of Snapchat that was a copycat
did not work out, right?
So there's other areas
in which Facebook failed,
but Facebook overall as
a company has done great.
Just because you're smart doesn't mean
you're always going to succeed
with everything you try or touch.
But every time you do something,
you will learn new things,
you will make mistakes,
and if you learn from these mistakes
and avoid making 'em over and over again,
you'll actually increase your odds
of succeeding as time goes on.
And the best way to do this
is not just to learn from your mistakes,
but it's also to learn from
the mistakes of others.
Rockefeller, Carnegie, all these people
who were entrepreneurs years
ago in the 1800s, 1900s,
they themselves used business
principles and concepts
that are still applicable
in today's world.
Sure, we have the internet,
but the same strategies
and concepts that they used
are still applicable, right?
So learn from their mistakes.
Learn what worked for them
and what didn't work them,
why, and bring that into
what you're doing today.
So conversion optimization
is like dating, right?
So if I go up to a random person,
let's say the lady looking
down on her laptop,
anyone, Unbound shirt, what's your name?
What's your name?
- [Nadia] Nadia.
- Nadia, if I say will
you marry me right now,
chances are you're going to say?
All right, if she was single,
she would still probably say no.
Why would she say no?
(laughing)
Yes, she is smart,
but what's the other reason?
- [Audience Member] Not enough data.
- Okay, not enough data, but what else?
If someone comes up to you
in the middle of the street
and just says, will you marry me,
I don't care if they look,
they're a Victoria's Secret model, right?
Why would you say no,
or I don't care if they're Brad Pitt.
- [Audience Member] I don't know you.
- Exactly, you don't know 'em.
That's right.
Whoever said, give
yourself a pat on the back.
That's the way the internet works, too.
Why would you expect someone
to just come to your website
and be like, hey, buy
something for $1,000.
Okay, here's my credit card, right?
I wish the world worked like that,
but it doesn't.
But once you get to know people,
they're much more likely
to say yes, right?
Just like you date someone,
get to know 'em, move in together,
you ask 'em to marry you.
Hopefully they say yes.
If not, you kind of wasted some time.
But here's what most funnels look like.
Someone comes to your website, sign up,
and you generate some sales, right?
So I decided to do something.
I'm like, you know what?
Why not flip around the funnel?
Why not get people to
actually use a product
before I actually try to charge 'em?
Put in a URL first.
From there, what's your goal?
Start creating product, right?
It actually caused a
52.11% increase in signups,
all by switching it around.
Still asked for their credit card.
Just got more signups.
Why, because people got to play around
with the product a bit
before they actually bought.
Focus, focus, focus.
You heard the say, us Generation
Y kids have ADD, right?
That's what we all say.
Well, if you have ADD, you know,
you got to figure out how to focus,
and here's the thing.
There isn't enough time in
the day to do multiple things.
Think of it this way.
I'm a single guy.
I'm 27 now.
And if you think about it,
there's only 24 hours in a day,
seven days a week.
Let's say you sleep.
I need my eight hours
of sleep or I'm cranky.
It's like, you know, you
hang out with framily,
whatever, maybe, you don't really have
more than 70 to 80 hours
to work every single week.
If you barely have money
and there's not enough
time in the day to work, right,
to get everything done
that needs to be done,
how can you do multiple businesses
and do two businesses at the same time?
It's just not going to work.
Unless you're Elon Musk,
and I got to say, that
guy's a badass, right?
Like, when people ask him,
what do you do,
he can say, "Oh, one of my
companies competes with Toyota."
What's the other one do?
"I compete with NASA," right?
Like, he's a badass,
and he's the CEO of both of 'em.
And they're billion-dollar companies.
Unless you're Elon Musk,
don't try to do two
companies at once, right?
He put in, when people
didn't give him money,
in one interview, he's like,
"No one would give me money.
"I just put in 100 million
bucks of my own money," right?
Like, the guy's really a badass,
and probably none of us
in this room are him,
so don't try to do two businesses at once.
Focus.
Idea number six.
Get personal.
And I got this idea
from Facebook years ago.
Do you remember when you were on Facebook,
like, five years ago and
you would see all these ads,
your friend has a crush on you?
You remember that?
Those guys made a killing.
They were spammers, but
they made a killing.
And I'm not saying you should spam,
but you can actually learn a
lot from these kind of people.
Don't do the shady stuff they're doing,
but take the ethical
tactics that they were doing
and replicate them and throw out
the shady business model part.
So dating sites make you feel special,
very special, right?
They tell you when you go to these sites,
OkCupid, Match.com,
what else is there?
Tinder doesn't do it,
'cause Tinder's mobile-based.
Actually, Tinder kind of does it.
It's geo-based, right?
They make you feel special.
So if I'm logging in from
Vancouver and I go to Match.
I don't know if Match is here.
It's an IC company.
It usually says, hey, there's, you know,
5,639 singles in Vancouver.
What are you waiting for, right?
It's like, oh, that's a lot
of single people in Vancouver.
Maybe I should sign up.
So we tested this out on timsykes.com.
I'm determined to create a
millionaire trader in Las Vegas.
My only question is will it be you, right?
Tim is down to create
a millionaire trader.
He's done this many times.
We started using geo-based data.
The signup rate actually
increased quite a bit.
We decided to do the
same thing on my site.
Do you want more traffic?
Hey, I'm Neil Patel.
I'm determined to make a
business in Las Vegas successful.
My only question is will it be you?
The best part about this is
for all the people around Las
Vegas or cities like that,
geo-targeting's not exact,
so it may say Las Vegas
even when someone's
like 30, 40 miles away.
You know how many emails
we were getting per day?
Like, hey, I applied.
I really want to do it.
I'm not based in Las Vegas,
but I'm only 20 miles away.
I can drive.
Traffic's not too bad, right?
People were really engaged,
like, wow, this is personal.
It's just an opportunity for
someone who's in Las Vegas.
Heck, he doesn't service and nor do I,
we don't service people
in Hamburg, Germany,
but if you go to the page,
it'll show up Hamburg, Germany
if you're in Hamburg, Germany, right?
That's what we do.
Then we also took this data
and decided to throw it,
throw out all the steps from geo,
popping in the name,
changing it to multiple-step
process instead of single,
so that way people are
actually feeling special
throughout the whole signup process.
You know what happened?
68% increase in engagements.
So conversions jump roughly
30% from signing up,
but engagement was more important.
What I mean by engagement,
I'm talking about LTV of the customer.
Customers were staying 68% longer,
and I know that may not
sound like a big deal, right,
but it's really hard to keep customers.
If your customers are
only staying for a year
and you're getting 'em to
stay for an extra, like,
seven months, that's huge, right?
That's seven months' worth of extra money.
So personalizing a site,
making people feel special like
they do on the dating sites
can really help you grow your revenue.
I really love what I'm doing.
Not just so much where people are like,
oh, find your passion and go do it.
A lot of people claim it's
something they really like.
But I enjoy marketing so much
and creating companies for marketers
that I work my butt off
and it doesn't seem like work, right?
I can work 70, 80-hour weeks consistently
and not have to worry about it.
It never stresses me out.
I never feel like, oh,
I should take a vacation or any of that.
I really do enjoy working.
I'm a workaholic.
So loyalty matters.
Hiring good employees isn't enough.
You need to hire loyal employees
because shit happens that's
just not in your control, right?
I was part of this
company called Fruitcast.
I put in 100 grand, me and my co-founder,
and this dude came up to us with the idea.
We set up a business,
we barely did any work,
we just put in more of the capital.
It was when podcasting was hot.
Everyone remember podcasting,
that thing that no one listens to anymore?
So when podcasting was hot
and you just had the iPod
without the video, right,
we created this company
kind of like Google Adwords,
but for podcast, 'cause it was taking off.
We could automatically take your podcast
that you were creating
and put in ads for you
and do on-demand pay-per-listen model,
and it was hot, right?
A lot of companies were
hitting us up, ad agencies.
We even had a lot of buyout offers.
And it didn't go through.
The reason the buyout
offer didn't go through,
and it was from a big search giant,
you can take a guess, there's only three,
but the reason it didn't go through,
'cause he was like, dude,
why would I want to work for 'em?
That would be stupid.
I like doing my own little business.
And I'm like, dude,
I just gave you 100
grand for this business
and you're telling me you're
not passionate about it
and you don't want to do it full time
or you don't care for it?
I'm like, why'd I give you
the 100 grand for it, right?
So I learned that it's really important
to have passionate people.
Like, the other thing to keep in mind is,
I've also been through lawsuits,
class action lawsuits.
When you don't have loyal people
that don't fit in with your culture,
they're going to leave you.
During my last class action lawsuit,
my last and hopefully only one,
we actually had no employees who left us,
which is pretty amazing, right?
You're running out of capital,
customers were leaving us,
and the class action lasted a long time,
like over a year,
and no one left us,
and it was because they
really fit in with culture.
We took care of 'em.
Me and my co-founders do whatever we can
for our team members, right,
'cause it's like, they're a family.
So it's like, when you treat 'em that way,
they're going to treat you that way,
and it's a win-win situation.
So lessons learned.
Hire people who fit within your culture.
Tony Hsieh does a great job of this.
When you're interviewing,
he'll pay you to quit right away,
and if you want to quit
and take the money,
you can take the money,
but he knows that you're a bad fit.
Make sure everyone has similar short-term
and long-term models.
People try to buy you out.
If everyone on the team doesn't have
that same goal and objective,
a lot of your team members won't go,
which means that your company's
not going to be valued the same.
You also need to be transparent.
I've always been open with my team,
and by being transparent,
it's helped create a good
culture and a healthy one
where they stick with me and
I continually stick with them.
You have to keep in mind,
humans are inherently lazy.
When you're blogging, you
need to be consistent.
If you're going to write a post,
write continually.
If you're going to write once a week,
you better write once a week.
I don't care if it's a holiday.
I don't care if you're sick.
If you're going to do once a month,
then stick to once a month.
Worst case, you should
stick to once a month,
and then if you have more time,
ramp it up to twice a month
and once a week, et cetera.
I got lazy one time with my current blog,
Quick Sprout, years ago,
and I took a whole month off.
My traffic was climbing
almost every single month
prior to that.
When I took a month off,
how many months do you think it took
for me to recover that traffic?
Three.
I had to blog consistently every week
for three months just
to recuperate my traffic
back to where it was
versus it growing on a consistent basis.
Now sure, the blog won't ever go to zero,
but it does go down,
so by continually adding more information,
you're going to find growth.
When you're also doing this,
you need to create a conversation.
Well, in blogging,
you can use the words you and I.
It helps create a conversation, right,
creates that illusion.
So if you read my content on Quick Sprout,
you'll notice a lot of yous and Is.
Helps keep people engaged,
makes 'em scroll longer, stay on the page,
et cetera, comment, right?
In essence, I'm creating
a virtual conversation,
and I kid you not, it works.
The other thing is don't
act smart when you blog.
Dumb it down.
So not only should you
create a conversation
by using you and I, keep it simple.
Don't try to be more sophisticated
or smarter than your readers.
You need them as much as they need you.
You actually may even
need 'em more, right?
So be friendly with them.
Once you got the conversation piece down,
you need to focus on headings, right?
So you see headings.
Within your blog posts,
you need to use them three to five times.
This will help you break it up.
It keeps it simple, right?
How many times have you guys
signed up for a service?
Once, twice, three times?
I bet all of you guys have signed up
for more than 50 services in your lifetime
in which you're putting in
your name and email somewhere.
Would you agree with that?
Probably even 100, right?
What happens if I could tell you
that you can sign up for a product
without giving your name,
email, and password?
Would you be happy,
assuming it doesn't
break any privacy laws,
all your information's secure, et cetera?
Would you be happy?
Yes, right?
Well, you can.
So Buffer.
Log in with Twitter, log in with Facebook,
log in with LinkedIn,
or log in with an email address.
A lot of people are doing it.
I understand, they're a
social media business,
but anyone can do this.
We do this at KISSmetrics.
KISSmetrics sells B2B
solutions for businesses.
So you would think, oh,
people would use their
corporate email address,
you know, Facebook wouldn't work,
especially Gmail, right?
You guys wouldn't think Gmail would work
for a business that only
sells to other businesses?
Well, we decided to test it out.
Sign up with your Google account.
We didn't even give another option
that stated also sign up with your email.
We made you sign up with
your Google account, right?
Just that one little change
increased signups by 59.4%.
Then we decided to do something funny.
I can see the Unbound
person shaking their head.
You're going to try this, aren't ya?
All right, try this after.
It even worked better.
So we decided to do something else.
We're like, you know what?
I hate signing up.
I don't mind logging into sites,
but I don't like signing up.
So we decided to change
a call to action button
to say log in with Google, right?
We got another 22% increase in signups
just by changing the word
from sign up to log in.
So if you take both the convertor rates,
the 59 and the 22, it compounds, right?
You're looking at roughly, like, a 90-plus
percent increase in conversions.
That's not too shabby.
All by just using Google.
And we have customers like
Microsoft, Amazon, et cetera.
They all signed up
through the Google funnel.
And you would think people at
Microsoft aren't using Gmail.
I can prove to you they are, right?
So if someone's telling you,
oh, it's not going to work,
it's not what we're testing,
you know what, try it out.
You can't go wrong.
Just send 10% of your traffic.
What's the worst that's going to happen?
So try out these tactics.
It doesn't matter if you're e-commerce,
lead gen, a service-based business.
You can always test out these tactics.
I've done it on all these
types of sites and it works.
I guarantee you actually will see
more growth from your business.
If you don't, you can email me,
heckle me, and I'll actually
give you free advice.
Take care, thanks.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ernesto Bal asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Neil say
that really inspired you
or really motivated you,
or what did you learn from him?
Please leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout-out to Cyrus Webb.
Cyrus, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and tweeting it out as well.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(air rushing)
- Here's a KISSmetrics story.
Four years ago, which
is roughly one share,
maybe a bit more than that now.
I think we're up four and a half,
we took a million dollars in seed funding
from some angel investors.
We created a version with that.
It was called Version 1.0.
We were going to create a
better Google Analytics, right?
Everyone use Google Analytics here?
Probably have some issues
with Google Analytics, right,
like, yeah, it could be better.
Well, we were going to
create a better version of it
and we were going to charge you for it.
What was the issue?
No one wanted it because they loved
how Google Analytics was free.
But I built it because I wanted it.
Terrible idea, right?
Spent a year on that.
Version 2, and at this point
we were running out of money,
so we had to raise another round.
We raised three million bucks.
Version 2, only took six months this time.
Didn't take a year.
We created a Facebook analytics company
off of Dave Mcclure's AARRR metrics,
you know, like the pirate, A-A-R-R-R,
something like that.
That didn't work out as well.
We found out these
Facebook gaming companies
actually don't make that much money
or have a ton of money to spend on games.
Don't believe me?
Look at Zynga's stock, right?
It's in the shitter, so.
(laughing)
It really is.
These games last for, like, six months
and then they go down.
But that's who I was trying
to build a product for.
Learned the hard way that
they have a ton of data
which is costly to compute
and they don't want to
spend much money at all.
Version 3 took less
than 30 days to launch.
Funny enough, that was the version
that we actually currently have.
We iterated on it,
but it's the version that
people continually pay for
and the business is thriving, right?
Lessons learned from this?
Create a minimal, viable product.
It's Eric Ries', you know,
like, preaching his whole thing,
MVP, Lean Startup, great book.
Funny enough, he's been an advisor
to our company from day one,
but it took us, like, a year
and a half to get there.
I don't know why, but,
you know, we learned the hard way.
As you can see,
I'm on the business side,
not the engineering side,
and my co-founder's also a business guy.
So, but it's worked out.
So when you release a product
and you do the minimal viable product,
what that is is you
get something out there
as quick as possible and you get feedback.
For example, when we want to launch
a new feature or report,
we actually survey people
and just get their input,
and then we'll go create
wireframes and designs
that are clickable.
We won't even develop it,
and be like, hey, what
do you think about this,
and we'll put fake data in there,
and people are like, oh cool,
I like this, or I want to see this,
or I wish I could do that, blah blah blah.
We keep on iterating and
eventually we'll create a version
that actually works and
let people test it out
with their data and iterate more
until we get product market fit,
which means that people are saying
I'm really satisfied with your product
and I'd be devastated
if it no longer existed,
which means that they'll talk
about your product a lot,
the word of mouth marketing will spread,
they'll be willing to pay a lot more,
churn will decrease,
stuff like that, right?
So go for product market fit.
You can Google it to look at
the product market fit pyramid
and how that works.
And again, don't worry about perfection
when you're doing all this kind of stuff.
It just helps you get
out products much faster.
People will drop off unless you give 'em
a reason to stick around.
So one of my buddies, Mike,
we were talking and I'm like,
what makes you stick around?
And we were drinking beers,
and he's like, those
virus checkers, right?
He runs McAfee and Norton
on his computer all the time
and it actually causes
him to stick around,
'cause when it tells him there's a virus,
he has to stay and find out what it is
so he finishes the whole test.
Why he gets viruses on his computer?
That's a whole different issue, right?
But he has that problem,
so he's always sticking around for McAfee.
So I decided to analyze people's websites
and tell 'em that there's errors.
As they progress, there's
more and more errors, right,
assuming we find 'em.
Instead of showing 'em the errors,
I say put in your information, right?
Got more people to put in information.
Gave 'em a reason to stick around
because there was like,
there's errors, right?
63.5% increase in responses.
We were collecting leads.
So not only were we getting more leads,
but we had a 63-plus percent increase
in people actually following up
because we were giving 'em
a reason to stick around.
If you're an entrepreneur
and you're looking
for aggressive growth,
there's three things you need to do.
One, you need to leverage
content marketing.
Give away the best information out there.
The information needs to be so good
that your competitors
won't dare to copy you.
Number two, you need to
create unique business deals.
So everyone looks at marketing
as the best way to grow.
I actually see it as business development
is the best way to grow.
If you can strike up interesting deals
with other businesses that
already have a user base,
you can quickly grow and expand
your user base really fast.
For example, if I run a marketing company
and I'm trying to get more business owners
and websites to sign up to my stuff,
GoDaddy's a perfect
company to partner with
'cause they already have
millions of customers.
The third tip I would say
is just working really hard,
in which people want to grow,
but they don't want to put in
the time and energy to grow.
If you're not willing to put in the hours
and keep at it relentlessly
whether you fail or you succeed,
you just can't stop no matter what.